#HASHTAGWARS!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
IF YOU REMEMBER, EARLIER
IN THE PROGRAM, I TOLD YOU
THE NEW "STAR WARS" CAST
WAS ANNOUNCED, AND BECAUSE THE
INTERNET, THERE WERE NEGATIVE
REACTIONS BECAUSE ALWAYS.
I AM PERSONALLY VERY EXCITED
BECAUSE THERE COULD BE A LOT
WORSE THINGS THAT COULD HAPPEN
TO THE "STAR WARS" FRANCHISE,
AND I WOULD LIKE YOU GUYS TO
COME UP WITH SOME.
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS
#WORSESTARWARS.
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE "DARTH MAUL
COP" OR "DANCING WITH THE DEATH
STARS" OR "TATOOINE AND A HALF
MEN."
SO ANYTHING IN THE "STAR WARS"
UNIVERSE, CHARACTERS, NAMES OF
THINGS, ANYTHING IN THE "STAR
WARS" UNIVERSE, #WORSESTARWARS.
60 SECONDS AND GO.
RANDY.
>> KEEPING UP WITH THE
CALRISSIANS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JASON.
>> HAN SOLO FLEX.
IT JUST BECOMES AN INFOMERCIAL
FOR AN HOUR.
>> Chris: POINTS.
KYLE.
>> KATHIE LEE AND YODA.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: RANDY.
>> QUI-GON JINN AND JUICE.
I GOT MY MIND...
>> Chris: LOVE IT.
>> READY?
I GOT MY MIND ON MY WOOKIE
AND MY WOOKIE ON MY MIND.
>> Chris: POINTS.
(APPLAUSE)
KYLE.
>> SKLAR WARS, IT'S "STAR WARS"
BUT WITH THESE GUYS!
I BEAT THEM TO IT!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: YEAH, POINTS.
RANDY.
>> JAY-EWOKING,
WHERE JAY LENO...
(LAUGHTER)
...APPROACHES AN EWOK ON
THE STREET AND TRIES TO MAKE HIM
LOOK STUPID BY ASKING HIM DUMB
QUESTIONS.
>> Chris: KYLE.
>> FLESHLIGHT SABERS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: OH, MY GOD, THAT'S THE
BEST THING I'VE EVER HEARD OF
IN MY LIFE!
WHY IS THAT NOT A THING?
POINTS!
OH, MY GOD.